Holly about a year or so ago and you
were working at the time you in a very
high paid corporate job yeah and after
meeting me you quit your job pretty much
instantly yeah which is a ballsy move
however it's been a year or so now how's
how's business um amazing honestly uh
it's changed my life um I was in a highp
high pressure job now I have my own
property business um we've got a
portfolio of 10 properties worth 3.2
million and I just love getting up every
day to work on my business it's amazing
how much does your property business
turnover per year uh it's about quarter
of a million just under well super proud
of you what would you advise be to
someone watching this that is really
wanting to get out their job and get
into property I'd say 100% get educated
first you need the knowledge to be
successful um it would be crazy to to
leave your job without having that to to
support your journey so 100% do that
Winners on a Wednesday come in sooning
World on Hollow thank you boom come and
meet me at the crash course1 tickets
Link in buyer